the reason i care about being strong is
so i can not only protect myself or
protect people i care about the reason i
want to be rich is not only so i can buy
myself stuff so i could provide for my
family yeah every every single position
of strength comes with a derivative of
softness underneath it there's some
emotion involved in it if i was really a
person who had no soft side whatsoever
and i didn't give a [ __ ] i don't think
i'd be the way i am i think i'd be
complete opposite i think there are
people like that who are so inherently
selfish
but those people are not successful
people those are people who sit on the
couch all day watch tv smoke weed and do
nothing
let me tell you guys a true story i was
21 years of age this is not long ago 21
years of age yesterday was my birthday
and me and andrew what do we eat on my
birthday
okay why did we eat kfc because when i
was 21 me and andrew used to have no
food i used to drive my broken
volkswagen golf to the kfc restaurant in
dunstable united kingdom and i used to
sit in my car
and you couldn't ever eat anyone's
leftover food if they ever had their
mouth on it but at kfc they used to buy
buckets and i would sit and wait for
people to stay outside eat their meal
and leave the bucket on the table and i
used to go and take that bucket three or
four pieces of chicken and i used to
collect 20 30 40 pieces of chicken that
were perfectly fine left in the buckets
and i used to go home and i used to
freeze that chicken i mean andrew would
break it up put it in our rice and that
was our meal that's what sustained us
for that hard year that year we had when
i was 21 and you were 22. that's how
broke we were i used to scavenge chicken
from kfc because i thought [ __ ] i'm not
dying and i'm losing my kickboxing
fights because i don't have enough
protein what am i going to do to make it
through today that's how broke i was and
that's a sad story if you never make it
out to me that's a happy story that's a
story of triumph now it's like hey
andrew it's my birthday what we doing
kfc and it's a big joke we sit there in
our kfc laughing about how we used to
scavenge kfc chicken if you're a man
who's never had hard times you're not a
very good man any man who's had an easy
life is going to fall and collapse in
the face of adversity and the whole
point of being a man the whole point of
masculinity is the ability to resist
i'll tell you the coolest thing about
being rich because i'm a little bit rich
now
a little bit
the coolest thing about being rich is
remember when i was broke
that's all it is
having money in and of itself really
isn't that interesting you buy the house
you buy the car you buy the watches you
buy some clothes blah blah it's boring
it's only cool to sit there with my
brother
in [ __ ] nurse restaurant with salt
bae being an idiot
spending 15 g's and saying do you
remember stories do you remember when we
didn't have a penny right 15 grand for
dinner we never had 15 grand in our
savings account in our lives do you
remember that time we were living off
those 10 p packs of noodles for two
weeks
you need this juxtaposition there is no
light without dark you will not
appreciate your six-pack unless you
didn't have one and you had to earn it
that's how the world works
why i think i fight
do i enjoy it now
do i enjoy training no do i enjoy
cutting weight no am i nervous yes do i
think to myself what am i doing yes
completely
unfortunately
it's one of those things you're either
born with you're not
and
the only way i can explain it to try and
make it make any sense
is that if i'm not doing something
which is either extremely difficult or
extremely stressful
i'm in a perpetual state of crippling
boredom
i can't explain it i see other people
live their lives and they're like oh i
can't wait for the weekend because i
want to watch this movie
i think who cares about a movie you're
looking forward to the weekend for a
movie looking forward to the weekend to
get drunk like these things to me are so
mundane
they mean nothing
and if i don't fight if i'm not in a
situation where i'm stressed or worried
or concerned
i'm just perpetually bored and boredom
is crippling if you're an intelligent
person and you've got
a good brain on your shoulders you can't
just sit there bored you know
so most smart people take the academic
group to avoid boredom they learn learn
learn learn but that's never really
interested me either although i've
always been an intelligent guy and i've
always done well academically
it never really interested me and then i
see people climb out everest or jump off
buildings or do base jumping or the guy
who jumped from space people think
what's he doing he's crazy i understand
because some people can't live normal
life some people cannot just function
nine to five office job get drunk at the
weekends that is not for some
individuals and it's not for me so i
have to find something which keeps me
physically tired enough
to stop me going awol
um and mentally tired enough and i've
chosen fighting because without this
when i'm not in training i wake up every
day and think okay what do i do today
it's 9 a.m on a tuesday i'm bored
everyone's at work i'm bored and i'll
end up doing something crazy i'll either
have drunk
or
on the eurostar
or you know it's just it's just a random
lifestyle i'm constantly looking for
never-ending entertainment and it
doesn't exist i think the only thing
that could stop me fighting is if i had
enough money to constantly entertain
myself unless i'm a billionaire i need
something that keeps me focused and
keeps me occupied in life with fighting
i have to train twice a day and i have
to train hard and the stress can be the
stress it brings in every aspect can
replace fun and my mind is occupied it
occupies me the only way i can try and
explain it it occupies me and i could
never stop doing this even if i lost a
hundred fights because i'm not built to
live a normal existence i can't do it i
couldn't just have a kid with some girl
and sit at home and work a little bit
and relax
i've never relaxed my entire life i
don't know what relaxing is it's just
not me
[Music]
i think that money bites freedom and
freedom buys happiness
i think that the rich people of the
world the number one most intelligent
thing they did was convince poor people
that money isn't happiness and i think
they did that to prevent revolts i'm not
saying money is the only thing that can
make someone happy i'm not saying money
alone will make you happy
but money is certainly a factor to to
happiness
so the rich people always say money
doesn't buy happiness but do they ever
give their money away so give your money
away i have a charity which i own which
takes care of street dogs in romania
so i rescue dogs that's really lovely
have you ever been in love absolutely i
completely believe in love
i am a massive advocate for love i'm a
massive advocate for
men and women being in love with each
other i'm not one of them evil predators
or one of them playboys who thinks women
are just for sex not at all
if you're sick in bed the first thing
you do is call a woman right
you don't call your boys when you're
sick in bed or you call you call a woman
right like there's a very sacred
interaction between men and women i love
the idea of family i love the idea of
children i love the idea of being in
love with a woman i love the idea of her
loving me i absolutely and utterly
believe that men and women are made to
be together i absolutely and utterly
believe that men and women should be in
love with each other i believe a woman
should love her man the man should love
her woman
i have women who i'm completely head
over heels in love with
i ain't gonna take [ __ ]
i start saying i won't leave you if you
disrespect me
but it doesn't mean i don't love her i
i don't know this idea people think that
you can't love a girl that a nurse
complete garbage i mean that's that's
low level [ __ ] i love having a woman who
loves me if i'm sick she actually cares
i like this idea you're just gonna spin
plates forever and just endlessly have
pointless sex then die i think that's
awfully sad you should want love and you
should want the idea of children you
should want all of those things
i mean this with all due respect
absolutely no patronization right but i
am compared to all of you a relatively
old man and i'm a well-lived man i've
been to lots of places i've done lots of
things you know what the most beautiful
thing in the world is
it's love and i mean this in a non in a
non-corny way when a man truly loves a
woman and a woman truly loves a man and
they're together right or die no matter
what that is truly beautiful let me tell
you something let me tell you something
a man can do things that men do and
still be completely obsessed and head
over heels in love with his woman